KD he said because I went to the
Warriors He's speaking on the goat
conversation why is he not in the goat
conversation I think KD is one of the
greatest scores we've ever seen the way
KD scored the ball is so effortless he's
never seen a bad shot like he going to
get you 31 points on 14 shots that is a
normal KD Knight obviously I'm not one
that's going to be like KD's
championships aren't real stop it
there's no Championship that's not real
Steph didn't get the credit that Steph
gets to day until 2022 when he led this
team to a championship and won the
finals MVP when all else was failing
Steph said all right fellas come on
let's go there period you got to go do
what Steph did to get to that
conversation